نبدا هذه الساعه من السودان وتصاعد
الخلافات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
حيث قال مصدر في الجيش للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع ادخلت ناقلات جنود الى
العاصمه الخرطوم واشار المصدر الى ان
ناقلات الجنود احضرت من منطقه الزرقاء
شمال دارفور الى الخرطوم مع عشرات
السيارات العسكريه مشيرا الى ان الجيش لا
يعلم ما هي دواعي نشر تلك العربات حتى
الان
وقال مصدر من الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان
قوات الدعم السريع لم تنسحب من مدينه مروي
حتى اللحظه رغم رفض لجنه امن الولايه
وجودها واشار المصدر الى ان الجيش
السوداني نفذ انتشارا كبيرا حول مطار مروي
شمل نشره ناقلات جنود وسيارات مزوده
بمدافع وكان مصدر عسكري سوداني قال ان
قوات الدعم السريع حركت قوات ضخمه في
مدينه مروي دون اخطار الجيش واضاف المصدر
ان الجيش استدعى قوات من مناطق اخرى
لمواجهه الموقف وقال المصدر ان القوات
المسلحه طالبت قوات الدعم السريع
بالانسحاب من منطقه تمركزها الجديد في
مروي في غضون 24 ساعه وان لم تفعل فسوف
تجبر على ذلك